-The last time you were here
was a while back,
but I had -- you sent over
a mascot to the show.
-Yep.
-This is the mascot you made
for a field piece.
That's Chiijohn.
-That's right.
That's right.
I remember, I texted you
not long before they arrived
-Yeah.
-Kind of just really like
selling you on the idea
as a small unit of time.
-Yes.
-It's like "This will take 10,
15 minutes maximum."
What I did not realize,
at that point,
was that they don't speak
at all.
-Yes.
-So, there are Japanese
mascots -- mascotees?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what the technica
job title is -- inside there
So, they don't
speak English,
but they also
won't speak at all.
-Right.
-So, they had a translator
so I could speak to them.
But then, they would not respond
out of character at all.
They basically went
full Daniel Day-Lewis
inside two otter costumes.
Yeah.
-And it is -- I will tell yo
first of all, it was true.
You said, "This will take
10 minutes."
It absolutely did.
-You're welcome.
-It is so unnerving...
-Yes.
-...to have a silent masco
stare at you.
-It is really -- It seems
charming, and initially it is.
But then, you look through
the grill of the eyes,
and you see the silhouette
outline of someone
you don't know
who will not speak to you.
-Yeah.
-And whenever you give them,
like, basic instructions,
they'll just respond --
again, in character --
with a kind of "hee, hee, hee.
And you go "Okay. Okay."
I get the "hee, hee, hee.
I really do.
But can we go over there
for a second take?"
-Yeah.
-It is genuinely unnerving
But --
they didn't speak a single -
I was with them
for two days.
They didn't say
a single word.
And then, during breaks,
they were still in character
kind of grabbing
each other's tail
while everyone else is eating,
going, "Is this all day?"
-It's also unnerving to thin
that you spent that much tim
with two people you could no
describe to the police.
[ Laughter ]
If they did something terrible
they would be like,
"What did they sound like?
What did they look like?"
And you'd have nothing.
-That's right.
You say "I don't know."
They say, "This story
just doesn't add up.
Two days,
they said nothing."
"No. I can describe the outlin
of a human head."
-It was like sort of,
"Oh, and they did this a lot."
-They go "hee, hee, hee"
a lot --
presumably,
after they kill.
-[ Laughs ]
We are talking right now
on Super Tuesday.
-Yeah.
-When this is over,
will you go home?
Will you watch the returns
of Super Tuesday?
-No. I mean, it's -- look,
I'm glad it's finally here
-Yeah.
-But there is a lot --
there has been a lot of talk
about it today.
It's kind of been irritating
watching the news today,
just having them say,
"Who do you think is
gonna win this state?
Who do you think is
Just wait.
You're about
to find out.
People on the --
they're like kids...
-Yeah.
--...in the back row of a car.
"Oh, who -- who -- who's gonna
win Alabama, dad?"
"Wait for the exit polls.
Wait for the polls
to close.
Don't make me turn
this democracy around."
They just --
They just cannot help themselves
but want to know.
-Yeah.